then what do I do with my facing okay
well my next step is think about
quadrants so this is where you get that
familiar acronym that you were telling
me before a s T C right so you draw your
quadrants right and hopefully you've
seen this before
also it's etc or whatever acronym
mnemonic device you prefer to use and
then what I say is remember what each of
these refers to okay it refers to which
trig functions are positive in which
quadrants okay so what this means is in
the first quadrant which is north to 90
degrees all of the trig functions sine
and cos at an they're all positive from
North tonight when you get into the
second quadrant which is ninety to a
hundred and eighty degrees cosine
becomes negative 10 becomes native only
sign remains as the positive function
and it keeps on going around what's the
third quarter what range of angles do I
get one dated is 270 and in this
quadrant only is positive and then
lastly 270 to 360 cosine is positive the
other two are negative so in thinking
about these quadrants I then return to
the original question remember I ignored
the site when I was working this thing
up now I go back to the site this IKEA
is positive right so because it's
positive I'm gonna be for sign in the
first and second quadrants do you see
that if for example I had an theta
equals 1/2 which quadrants would I be is
first and third right if I had cos theta
equals half I would be first and fourth
make sense so you look at the sign you
compare it to which function you've got
and then you identify the quadrants you
need so I would say since sine theta is
positive okay
theta is in the first and second
quarters
now you don't really need to write this
amount of explanation in your actual
answer but because it's the first time
we've done this in a while I want to put
this involve all so that when you come
back to this rather than just see the
phrase first and second quadrants feel
like what on earth is that about this is
actually what's being implying okay you
think about your function you look at
its sign and then you identify the
questions that make sense so now I want
to put my base angle inside each of
these quadrants and work out what it's
equivalent to okay so in the first
quadrant it's easy the angle in here of
the base angle in that corner is just
the base angle as long as we call them
when you move over to the second
quadrant what does the basing will look
like in this quadrant
it's the supplement of theta so it's
gonna be 180 degrees minus theta okay
can someone help me out what about in
the third quarter what's it going to
look like it's 180 plus said actually
comes horizontal right 180 degrees plus
the base angle in your final quadrant
here again it's from the horizontal
everything's from the horizontal here so
whipping all the way around would be 360
and then you just go backwards a little
bit 360 degrees minus
okay so those great things there is what
the base angle becomes in each of these
quadrants now you hopefully identified
for me it's best in second functions so
you would say therefore theta equals
firstly 30 degrees that's my first chord
root solution oh and I even write this
just so I don't muck it up a hundred and
eighty minus 30 degrees that's my second
quarter itself so to simplify that
. done how do you feel about that is
that okay
feeling comfortable okay so I'm just
going to hit pause there and note that
this is I think the most for most people
the quickest that is way to remember
however I want to play that there are
lots of things that I dislike about this
method example why why is it STC why not
a CTS or 80s C like why is it that water
that's kind of mysterious but we just
kind of learned to acceptance you just
sort of say fine you know if I remember
and that's all I need to get the answer
right yes but why is why is s for
example why is that the second country
and not the third quarters right now I
did explain it but here's the thing most
students who remember this method all
they remember is just the order right
because that's in some ways all you need
to get the right answer okay so this
method doesn't need to be understood to
be used in other there are other areas
like for example why isn't 180 minus
theta and then 180 plus theta why is it
not why is it the horizontal why why is
it not from this line the vertical like
what do people having into vertical
lines what's up with that okay you can
make right angles off you might writing
the train was off there so why don't we
okay in fact if you have a look at what
these angles look
they formed this diagram maybe you want
to put this on the side of your work
what these angles look like is this is
the first quadrant angle theta right
what do you - they huh
looks like that you see that it's like
one 800 minus 180 plus look like that
and then 360 minus will look like that
so it kind of looks like a buck
when I first let this I was like yeah
why is it that why is it not like the
other way round like this like a um like
an hourglass you can still make
right-angled triangles in there and the
reason is well for most people for doing
step in no reason because someone said
so her you know so understating is not
required to use his method which is why
I don't like it as much
okay so if you remember something wrong
like for example if you identify the
quadrants wrong because you don't really
understand what is going on yeah I said
second quadrants by mistake but I can't
fix that error because I don't really
know why it's this